moritz se oponía no a la
remilitarización de esta región pero sin
embargo volvió a esta política que fue
iniciada bajo el mandato de derecha del
ex presidente sebastián piñera porque
cree que tomó esta decisión y que costos
podría conllevarle a boris este giro en
su estrategia entre quienes apoyan su
programa
correcto
santiago un cordial saludo
bueno el hecho concreto es que en las
últimas semanas desde pero desde que
asumió el nuevo gobierno que lleva un
poco más de dos meses que se
multiplicaron en el sur de chile
cortes de camino por dos de estas
razones por los lados barricadas y
cortes de ruta y efectuada por
comunidades mapuches y dos grupos
vinculados a la comunidad no escuchas y
por otro lado también cortes de ruta de
camioneros que en protesta por los los
primeros se compararon y cortaron el
tránsito de la del país que como todos
saldrán por la forma geográfica de chile
es muy fácil
interrumpir la comunicación lo cual
afectó gravemente el abastecimiento o
incluso la concurrencia de enfermos a
hospitales y el estado de emergencia
busca restablecer y garantizar el libre
tránsito en todo el territorio
de la educaría ahora obviamente esto
como lo he dicho presiente por hecho hoy
día y lo entiende que esto no es la
única medida con lo cual se dore fueron
problemas más profundos que requiere de
muchas otras medidas más políticas como
establecer un diálogo o más sociales
como es la compra de tierras y para
restituirla a las comunidades que han
sido afectados precisamente vinculado a
esto último no porque estamos ante un
problema histórico en chile que hasta
ahora ningún gobierno pudo resolver no
algunos representantes mapuches se han
mostrado abiertos a un diálogo con el
gobierno de boris tienen más chance es
boris de llegar a ser quien llegue a un
acuerdo entre el estado y los mapuches
bueno yo diría que la deuda es una deuda
del estado chileno no de un gobierno en
particular con los pueblos originarios
no soy objetivo en esto yo soy
pertenezco a la etnia aimara somos del
norte del país pero la situación más
difícil hoy en día se plantea con los
hermanos mapuches
este tema es parte de las deliberaciones
que ha desarrollado la convención
constitucional que está por terminar su
mandato y entregar y proponerle al país
un nuevo pacto social en el cual se va a
influir con un capítulo importante el
reconocimiento de los derechos a los
pueblos originarios y creo que seguro en
un camino democrático inclusivo y que
puede restablecer la paz social y
también los derechos de los pueblos
originarios